Hello, this is Dr. Kevin Conner's again in this video. We're going to talk about the kidney and bladder cancers.
Kidney and bladder cancer are becoming more and more common. We see them in our office
just
Much more than we did in years past. So it might be the
Exposure to pesticides and chemicals that were kind of being
Inundated with I don't know for sure, but we're seeing it more often in our office. Maybe
Maybe it's just our office, but
Certainly we see it being more common. Whenever we're diagnosed with any type of cancer, it's definitely a
Scary thing and we have a lot of questions.
All the cancers kidney and bladder no different are all separated in different divisions different cell types
They react differently the different cell types react differently to standards of care like different chemotherapies
So depending on what type of cell it is
Is that's part of what is going to be the diagnosis and that is going to shape the recommended treatment from a natural
Perspective the diagnosis is a little bit less important because we're not treating the disease we're treating the patient
We don't treat cancer. We treat the patients
So we're trying to build up your immune system. We're helping you detox
We're getting your body to be able to fight this disease
We're not fighting the disease. So as we get a cheek swab from our patients
We do a diagnostic test through that and then we do a diagnostic test through a salivary sample looking at a person's genetics
That's where we're coming up with the decision-making process on our part
What are we going to do specifically for this person's cancer in the realm of their diet?
We're looking for what is fueling the cancer and we're going to take that away not putting up on some radical diet that it's
The possible to stay up for any length of time
Then we're looking for cause we're testing for that cause or causes
Working at detoxing that if it's a pesticides or killing it if it's a
Bio-toxin then we're looking at what specific
Nutraceutical that is an herb or a supplement of some kind not a drug
But a natural remedy that's going to be your best cancer balancer
So I'm sure if you've had cancer for any length of time and you
Told the public your friends your family
You've got
Inundated with ideas from well-meaning people take this my sister's
Brothers friends uncles cousin did it and it really worked what they did
Ivy vitamin C or
Perchamined or you know, protocell or something I
Understand that it gets overwhelming. So our process is to help filter you through that
One of the big things that we hear in our office is people think that they can't do alternative care concurrently
If they're choosing to do
Conventional care at the same time. That's a really
Misunderstanding so nothing that we're going to recommend is going to interfere with anything that you do from a conventional
standpoint we have a lot of our patients are doing conventional care as well some have exhausted it and they failed that
That's why they look to us. I think that's I always think that's a little sad because
Really you should look to natural things first whether you do choose to do standards of care as well
We should be changing our diet changing our nutrition changing the environment that got us to where we're at now
AKA a diagnosis of cancer in order to make your outcome better
Certainly adding alternative care to your current protocol is going to do nothing but improve your outcome
And that's really what our goal is but like I said before it gets confusing
So our purpose is to get very specific on what was what we're going to take away from a dietary
Perspective what's fueling the cancer what we're going to use from a specific neutersunicals perspective to help your immune system
Be boosted to kill the cancer what we're going to do with frequency medicine to help
Rife technology improve your life because that's what we really want we want you to win
We want you to have more years to your life and a lot more life to your years than that quality of life factor is key
And no regardless of whether you choose our care or not
Please use our website download our material all my books are free
Good to say take advantage of it. Look at them
You know if you don't like everything just take the good things that you like out of there and utilize it
We're trying to be a ministry as much as possible to our patients
So and know that even if you don't choose care with us you're in our system. We're going to be praying for you
And that's going to be your key component right there. Thank you so much